IN THE JEFFREY EPSTEIN SAGA.
HISTORY SHOWED US THAT THERE IS
NOTHING LIKE THE PARTISAN DIVIDE
VOTE.
THE VOTE WAS 232-196, DISTRICTLY
ALONG PARTY LINES.
TWO DEMOCRATS DEFECTED AND VOTED
WITH THE REPUBLICANS.
IT'S SO CLEAR WHAT'S HAPPENING
HERE.
A VOTE TO SIMPLY FORMALIZE THE
PROCEDURE IS THE LEAST PARTISAN
VOTE, IT'S BENIGN.
IF THERE WERE A SCINTILLA OF
EVIDENCE OF AN IMPEACHABLE
OFFENSE, THAT VOTE WOULD HAVE
CROSSED PARTY LINES AS IT DID
WITH CLINTON AND NIXON.
PREDICTION, COMPLETE AND TOTAL
FAILURE ULTIMATELY IN THE
SENATE.
THE DEMOCRAT PLAYERS ARE
DISHONEST, DISINGENUOUS AND
DECEITFUL.
NANCY SAYS I WILL ONLY DO THIS
IN A NON-PARTISAN WAY.
>> IF AND WHEN THE TIME COMES
FOR IMPEACHMENT, IT WILL HAVE TO
BE SOMETHING THAT HAS SUCH A
CRESCENDO IN A BIPARTISAN WAY.
JUDGE JEANINE: SHE LIED, THE
WOMAN IS MORE THAN WILLING TO
IMPEACH IN A PARTISAN WAY, AS
WELL AS DIVIDE THE COUNTRY IN
HER POWER GRAB FROM THE RIGHTFUL
OCCUPANT OF THE OVAL OFFICE.
AND THE LYING SACK OF SCHIFF IS
SO DISHONEST HIS LAW LICENSE
SHOULD BE REVOKED.
HE LIED ABOUT THE SO-CALLED
WHISTLEBLOWER SAYING WE NEVER
TALKED TO HIM WHEN HE DID.
HE PERJURED HIMSELF IN CONGRESS
WHEN HE TALKED ABOUT WHAT THE
PRESIDENT SAID ON THE UKRAINE
PHONE CALL.
HE LIED WHEN HE SAID HE HAD
EVIDENCE OF RUSSIA COLLUSION.
HE WAS CUNNING AS HE CREATED A
NARRATIVE ABOUT UKRAINE WHILE
THE DEEP STATE CULTIVATED THE
SO-CALLED WHISTLEBLOWER WHO IS
REPORTEDLY AN OBAMA HOLDOVER,
WHO HAS APPARENTLY WORKED WITH
JOE BIDEN, JOHN BRENNAN AND
SUSAN RICE.
THESE LIARS CREATED YET ANOTHER
NARRATIVE SO THEY COULD IMPEACH
DONALD TRUMP.
WHISTLEBLOWERS HISTORICALLY WERE
REQUIRED TO HAVE FIRST-HAND
KNOWLEDGE.
BUT NO THE DEMOCRATS JUST
CHANGED THE RULES.
NOW HEARSAY CAN BE THE BASIS TO
TAKE DOWN A PRESIDENT.
YOU DON'T HAVE TO SIGHT, WITNESS
IT OR HEAR IT FIRSTHAND.
YOU CAN JUST TALK TO THE OTHER
MALCONTENTS IN THE WEST WING WHO
DON'T LIKE DONALD TRUMP, THEN
CALL YOURSELF A WHISTLEBLOWER.
EITHER SCHIFF IS STUPID OR HIS
EGO IS SO BIG THAT HE DOESN'T
KNOW THAT A PRESIDENT CAN ONLY
BE IMPEACHED WHEN A HIGH CRIME
OR MISDEMEANOR OCCURS LIKE WHEN
A PRESIDENT HAS DONE SOMETHING
SO OUTRAGEOUS AND BEYOND THE
NORM THAT WE AS A NATION SAY HE
NO LONGER DESERVES TO REMAIN IN
THE OVAL.
HE CAN NO LONGER BE OUR
COMMANDER-IN-CHIEF.
BILL CLINTON ENGAGING IN SEX
ACTS WITH AN INTERN IN THE OVAL
OFFICE WHILE PRESIDENT IS ABOUT
AS DISGUSTING ABUSE OF POWER
THAT THE #metoo MOVEMENT HAS
EVER CHOSEN TO IGNORE.
ARE YOU CHARRED NIXON APPROVED A
BREAK-IN OF THE DNC
HEADQUARTERS.
A CRIME IN AND OF ITSELF.
THE PRESIDENT'S SOUTHERNS WERE
PRESENT, THERE WAS
CROSS-EXAMINATION.
AND GET THIS.
ADAM SCHIFF HAS A CLOSED DOOR
INTERVIEW ON THE DAY THE
DEMOCRATS VOTED TO MAKE THE
PROCESS MORE TRANSPARENT.
WHAT A JOKE.
THIS GUY THINKS HE'S AN EMPEROR,
AND THEY ARE PROBABLY TELLING
HIM HIS CLOTHES ARE BEAUTIFUL.
THERE ARE NO RULES HERE.
THIS SO-CALLED FORMALIZING THE
IMPEACHMENT INQUIRY PUTS THE
PRESIDENT IN A WORSE PLACE THAN
ANY OTHER PRESIDENT WHERE
IMPEACHMENT WAS ATTEMPTED.
IF QUEEN NARNSY AND EMPEROR
ADAM'S WORLD, PRESIDENT TRUMP
HAS FEWER RIGHTS THAN AN MS-13
GANG MEMBER ILLEGALLY CROSSING
OUR SOUTHERN BORDER.
THIS IS LUNACY WITH THE LIARS,
LEAKERS AND LEFTISTS RUNNING THE
ASYLUM WITH RADICALS RESISTING
THE PRESIDENT, THE LAW, THE
CONSTITUTION AND THE AMERICANS
WHO PUT THIS MAN IN OFFICE.
THEY TAKE OUR LAWS AND OUR
CONSTITUTION AND THEY USE THEM
TO DISTORT FOR THEIR OWN ILLEGAL
PURPOSES.
AND DAMN IT, THEY HAVE GONE THE
AWAY WITH IT.
WHO THE HELL ARE THESE PEOPLE
WHO FLAUNT THE LAW AND GET AWAY
WITH IT, AND THEY EVEN LAUGH
ABOUT THE FACT THAT THEIR DEEP
STATE IS ACCOMPLISHING ITS GOAL.
I FOR ONE AM SICK AND TIRED OF
THIS NONSENSE, THE LIES, THE
HATE, THE HYPOCRISY, THE
LAWLESSNESS OF THOSE WHO HATE
THE MAN WHO EVERY DAY FIGHTS FOR
THIS COUNTRY.
I DON'T WANT TO HEAR THE SECRET
HEARINGS ARE STILL GOING ON.
I DON'T WANT TO HEAR SCHIFF HAS
THE RIGHT TO VETO A PRESIDENT'S
LAWYER, TO VETO TESTIMONY.
TO CLOSE THE DOORS.
WHO THE HELL DOES THIS GUY THINK
HE IS?
I HAVE BEEN IN CALIFORNIA, AND
TEXAS IN THE LAST 2 1/2 WEEKS.
I HAVE SPOKEN TO THOUSANDS OF
AMERICANS.
EVERYONE OF THEM WANTS TO KNOW
WHEN THE LEFTIST CRIMINALS ARE
GOING TO BE PROSECUTED.
WHEN THERE IS GOING TO BE
ACCOUNTABILITY.
NANCY PELOSI FOR ALL HER
NONSENSE ABOUT THE PRESIDENT NOT
BEING ABOVE THE LAW, THAT'S A
DOUBLE SPEAK, NANCY.
IT'S YOU AND YOUR GANG OF
CRIMINALS WHO ARE ABOVE THE LAW.
JOHN DURHAM BETTER BE PREPARED
WITH INDICTMENTS OR FACE THE
WRATH OF MAYOR CANS WHO BELIEVE
THEY ARE HELD TO A DIFFERENT
STANDARD.
IN THE END THIS IS ABOUT A
CONVERSATION OUR PRESIDENT HAD
WITH THE PRESIDENT OF UKRAINE.
AND TO BE HONEST WITH YOU IT'S
NONE OF YOUR DAMN BUSINESS WHAT
WAS SAID.
WE ARE NOT ENTITLED TO KNOW WHAT
BARACK OBAMA WAS PROMISING PUTIN
THROUGH MEDVEDEV IN THAT HOT MIC
MOMENT.
AND WE ARE NOT ALLOWED TO KNOW
WHAT THE QUID PRO QUO OF BARACK
OBAMA WAS WHEN HE GAVE $150
BILLION TO THE AYATOLLAH.
OR ARE WE JUST SUPPOSED TO
ASSUME HE WAS PLAYING SANTA
CLAUS WITH IRAN?
A PHONE CALL WITH UKRAINE
INVOLVES POLICY.
IF YOU DON'T LIKE THE
PRESIDENT'S POLICY, VOTE FOR
SOMEONE ELSE.
THE GUY ON THE OTHER END OF THE
PHONE SAYS THERE WAS NO
PRESSURE.
THE TRANSCRIPT MAKES IT CLEAR
THERE WILL BE WAS NO PRESSURE.
THE GUY ON THE OTHER END DIDN'T
EVEN KNOW MILITARY FUND WEREN'T
AVAILABLE.
SO HOW CAN THERE BE A QUID PRO
QUO?
AND I AM TIRED OF PROTECTING
THIS WHISTLEBLOWER.
BARACK OBAMA FIRED THE
WHISTLEBLOWER IN FAST AND
FURIOUS.
AND THIS WHISTLEBLOWER IS JUST A
PUNK TRYING TO GET HIS LEFTIST
CREDITS.
HE'S WHITE NOISE TOTALLY
IRRELEVANT TO THE CONVERSATION
WHICH IN ITSELF IS THE BEST AND
ONLY EVIDENCE.
TO ALL OF YOU OUT THERE, GET
OVER IT.
THIS IS A BUNCH OF NONSENSE.
THE DEMOCRATS ARE TEARING THIS
COUNTRY APART YET AGAIN.
THEY ARE WOOSS AND WHIM MUCHS
AND WEASELS.
THEY DON'T HAVE THE CHUTZPAH TO
FACE DONALD TRUMP IN NOVEMBER.
AND I DON'T BLAME THEM BECAUSE
HE WILL BELOW THEM OUT -- HE
WILL BLOW THEM OUT OF THE SWAMPY